little base.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, that is a good part, see.
Just barely.
Okay.
You got the tracker out of the armor.
I'd say that.
But you can't, I guess, mod this to 50 units.
You can mod the first one.
All right.
Hey, sadly, you want the second set of armor.
You still have the head of the chest plate and the legs for that armor,
but the foot or the boots are with red.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, let's pull it around a certain.
What?
Why are you saying?
Do you want, do you want this phone that I got?
Yeah, one phone that Roma has is probably broken.
Yeah, I got one radio mushy.
Yeah, the broken phone mushy and same the saplia has one radio mushy and one phone machine.
That one is still working.
But you have no way to know right now.
Okay, so I'll think you're with that later.
Okay.
Yeah.
Can they track the radio mushy or just?
They probably can.
Oh, mushy.
Saplia would know that they can track.
So they can track the phones and the mushy's.
Yes, the broken mushy, not anymore, probably.
But the other three, yes.
Okay.
All right.
So Saplia is going to toss the broken phone and then start to think her with the mushy's and phones.
Okay.
For the radio mushy, can you make a, I will only need one role for both of the radio mushy's because once you understand how one of them works, you could probably replicate that to the other one.
So, you can do the radio mushy's and the other one.
So, for phone mushy, you cannot break through it.
It's still locked, but you could take out the tracker inside it.
Okay.
I'll take the, out the tracker and I'll just mess up it later.
You have to access to the radio mushy's and stuff.
So, we'll talk to each other out of flake, the public frequencies on the private frequency you could talk to each other if you are ever split up.
I think one is already with Roma.
Yeah.
After I'm going to go after her, yeah, after a little while, satalia comes in with those,
mess with items as she says.
All right. I've just finished with messing with these items.
I'm going to go and retract it and we can use the mushy's for our needs.
I'm going to get my radio mushy to read.
I'm going to be like, you go and need this later.
Okay. What you can do is click on it.
Go to the triple dots, send to player and then send to read.
It didn't send.
I think it has to accept to maybe.
Oh, there it is.
They're perfect.
They got it.
I want you.
Yeah.
We'll get back to satalia.
So, if you can mess with it later.
You guys are still in like hooded.
I'm going to get a little bit of a load except for satalia.
But Baptiste is wearing their mask.
Lin is going to notice that and he says something like, oh, so you're the so-called masquerade that I've heard about.
I'm going to get a little bit of a load of that.
Okay, you, Baptiste should also have a couple of other masks and they also have their aliases.
If you can check Baptiste, there should be a bag for disguises inside this guy's there should be a wolf mask and a plague mask.
You can give those two red and the plague mask to red and wolf mask to Roma.
So if you guys can see you have like a transformation section in your actor part, which you can do is open up your sheet.
Grab your actor like for red it's raven just drag the actor onto your sheet and it should say appearance only transform.
Why is it not working for me?
Yeah, once they're in the state of house, Sap Leo will power down for armor.
Is it actually essentially parks it and then steps out, dropping the other, the marine suit of armor onto the ground and says don't drag drop in the like party one, open your character sheet and just drag the raven red or whatever into your character sheet and then should say appearance only and then transform.
That's what I did.
No, nothing happened.
Okay, let me do that for red and let me do that for Roma.
I'm going to do Roma.
You should also see restore transformation.
So whatever you want to get out of this disguise, you can click restore transformation to go back to your original token.
Same goes for dread not if they want to switch out the armor.
Transformations.
Yes, so you can just drag drop that and switch to that whenever you want if you don't want to do it right now that's fine.
So this is going to be your disguises for the heist if you guys if red does not want to be in disguise, you just want to he just wants to go invisible then they can also do that.
Then is going to look at saplia once they have a step out of the armor is going to say, exactly. Can you give me a moment can you step into my workshop.
I want to look around if you don't mind.
He wants to basically do a full checkup on your body to see if you can help with the catatonic shocks that you keep getting.
Yeah, exactly. It's up and out. Yeah, as saplia is stepping out. She is seen like rubbing her chest as like electricity arcs from her arm and chest like back and forth along her body.
All right, um, way it goes. So you plan on pulling them by doing some card tricks, a shirt's going to work looking at that piece.
And he goes, I have a set of playing cards we can we can test it out if you want.
So he's going to bring out the set of cards and he's going to set opposite to that piece.
So at this point, I'll say that he says like an ability that uses their blade. Let me see.
The uses a blade to essentially like harness their devil fruit and do something with it.
What this is going to do is instead of using that blade, they can use their fists to do the same thing. So that's basically the training for this for the whole four or five hours.
So we're going to be here the optist and a way they're going to just test out the playing card tricks.
So whenever we roll for like card set or something, they can have advantage on that our proficiency.
Okay, there's that. And so during that period, the optist is going to do that.
And the haplia would be under lens room or whatever he has a facility to test a bunch of stuff like blood work and all that.
While they do that, also lend before heading inside with spursus, a plia. Do you still have the line that you made?
What did you say?
The wine that you made, he asked for if you still have it or not.
Oh, yeah, it's just in my armor.
Okay, he's going to say maybe get one of these people to put it inside an actual bottle so you can present it to Harvard.
Yeah.
Well, give me like a portion of it. I want to test something.
Okay, yeah, sure. We'll go play once again.
Check it.
It's already made the food. Try to give it to Roma and Roma will drink it and just pass right out for the next like four hours.
All right, so Lynn takes out a small portion of the wine and gives it to whale and he goes like, what's this?
And then goes just drink it up. Don't ask questions.
And he's like, he looks at Lynn, Lynn suspiciously, but he's like fucking free wine, why not? So he chug said as soon as he chug said he's like, oh God, what the hell did you make me drink? And he's just going to pass out.
He wakes up pretty quickly, like a minute or so, but yeah.
Lynn heads back in the examination room to check on.
While you guys are doing that, Serika is going to ask Roma and red.
Oh, maybe we should head back out.
We have a back here. We can do some target practice or something if you want to do that.
So she leads you out of the building, essentially in the backyard, where you see just a bunch of like targets lying around some weapons and all that, but they're mostly right for us, did an old.
They just use it for like, they maybe used to use it at some point, but not anymore.
So Serika is going to go to house. I was black beard these days. I haven't seen the old fart in a while.
I'm going to be like, who? Who's black beard? Black hand. Fuck.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. And the magic, I make them like too close.
Does anyone care for spoilers of one piece?
Does anyone? I don't care. All right. There you go.
Red, that is.
We have finally, we have finally been revealed rocks, these are back.
And it has been confirmed he is the father of black beard.
Damn. Okay. I mean, this does not make any sense to any of these people.
Just say no. Yeah.
Yeah. That's cool. That's cool. I got a catch.
Yeah. It was just a newsman on chapter.
Serika asks how black beard these days and looking at red and Roma.
I'm all going back into like, who the fuck is that?
I'm going to be like, I don't know. It's been a while since I've been on his shit.
Yeah. Okay.
Oh, he's missing.
That's weird. The only time he went missing was when he was out in the grandline.
All right. And you know,
she just transformed her hand into guns and starts shooting at some of the targets in the place.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Time out.
How do you know who black hand hand is?
Oh, well, we had kind of like a running a couple years back at black hand.
Secondly, how do you know we know anything about black hand?
N-N-N told us that you're black hands people.
Lynn, just out here giving up our information.
Oh, I'm going to have to talk with him.
It's not really a secret. Have you read the newspapers?
What should we? We haven't done anything.
Oh, yeah. Not here, Ellie.
I'm not here.
Rome with the cannibal. Really? You haven't done anything.
I didn't need any.
I see.
I served him up.
That's, you know, where you drop again.
Exactly. I would ask bread about that.
I'm not sure if he's going to be able to do that.
Okay, let's switch back to Baptiste and Oil.
Let me see if I can add.
Do you have the player said, whatever.
What's it called?
Yeah.
The dice set.
No, no, you also need a.
What's it called?
Playing cards.
I'm going to drop them in your character sheet as well.
There should be playing cards now.
I'm going to say you guys are probably playing poker.
I'm going to say you guys are probably playing cards.
I really think we can trust them with the ring business.
I've dealt with too much shit regarding you and Viett.
Already.
I don't trust people easily.
But these guys, they kind of remind me of us.
Don't they before, you know, it over everything went to shit.
Lin is going to pull out the black ring that Saphia gave him before at the bramble shop.
Right.
And he's going to go, he's going to put it down on the table.
And we'll insert a kind of step a little back looking at the ring.
Lin mentioned something like, okay.
So this is not the first time we've seen a ring like this.
The one that we saw before was bigger.
Definitely.
But the same color and the engravings on this is exactly the same.
We don't have that ring anymore.
It was, let's just say it went out with the boom.
But a couple years back, Viett and Lin found another place.
And they sort of gathered some scriptures,
which had like imagery of these rings.
One of the copies of that scripture, I sent to Blackbeard, a Black Hand.
Sorry, I keep fucking backhand to maybe some, maybe check out what it says.
He has connections.
So I thought he would be able to tell what it is exactly.
The only thing I can tell that these rings mention some entities,
not of this word or maybe of this word.
I'm not too sure.
They just mentioned some entities.
And yeah, that's about all we know.
But the weird thing is how did Kiro find this ring?
It doesn't seem like something you can just run into.
One more thing is, he betrayed his fleet as I've been told.
But where was the ship?
Where was the people? It wasn't on that island.
I looked everywhere.
I looked everywhere on Abercrus.
I could not find a ship.
I could not find any dead body.
So we're exactly dead bodies.
It looks it's out there to maybe look for an answer.
I'm not sure.
All right, I'll just have to go.
You said we got aliens.
No one mentioned it.
It just looks at you like.
Look at look.
I want to like the balance.
And then we'll just keep on the ring.
There you go.
Guys, have your stuff.
What's the, what's the plan?
Who's going in?
Who's going to stay out?
What's happening?
Well, we're going to need a distraction for a.
Baptista.
We get switched the drink for the drink for the captain.
So I'm going in.
I'm going to be seeing it off in the back.
But I'm going in.
Who's going to play what?
Because if you all three went to head inside the casino.
And they marine knows that some of their people are missing.
They're going to have like patrols in the casino as well.
Because that's the only people they can hire to like guard the area.
So that idea was sapling a hides on the back.
Is either is either sapling or Baptista's hide or not 50 red was hiding on the back of.
On the back of that cheese and the other was hiding in the.
Back and waiting for the guy.
So who's going to be who?
I mean, red can just go invisible.
Or it can make someone.
I thought you were.
Red can go invisible and I have it.
I have an advantage on stealth checks.
But I also have a book hero in stealth checks.
But what I was saying is you have the marine armor.
There's marine patrols.
You have their radio frequency.
You could literally act as one of them.
So it's really red hiding in the bathroom waiting for the dude to pass out to steal his kids.
Baptista at the card.
Pable and then me just like awkwardly standing out in the belt with people like.
Watching people gamble.
But not actually gambling like you know those people that just be cheering people on.
From the back.
Yeah.
Wait wait and to like be a distraction.
So that way we could switch the drink that we already had bottled up.
For the captain.
Yeah.
Yeah, you be the distraction and then maybe I can act as like a marine that arrests you or something.
That's what I'm that's what I was thinking.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's that's what it worked.
What's red doing.
Fighting.
Yeah, waiting for the captain.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm going to let's see how this thing sounds.
Well, no, because reds wearing the marine boots.
So she'll be sitting in the toilet.
And when Marines come in, they'll just think it's a Marine taking the like a ship.
Okay.
Let me move to casino.
Oh damn, let's token us this.
And red has the other radio so she can be listening in on the police frequency.
Yeah, we got this.
Oh, why do I only have 10 HP though?
Yeah, this one.
Yeah, there you go.
This is red.
This is.
Oh, this is.
And this is first up to the enemy.
Let me change the.
Purins for a second.
Here in Sony transform.
All right.
So Baptiste is going to be accompanied by red and Roma.
Red, you can go invisible, but I mean, I don't know how long it lasts.
How long does it visit?
It only lasts for a minute.
I was saving that for.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank.
I'm not doing that here.
All right.
So he is going to head in with red and soon after.
So,
I'm,
I'm going to follow inside with them or like a little bit later.
A little bit later, but yeah, invisibility lasts one hour.
So what you guys see is like a couple of tables.
People just walking around with drinks and all that sitting on the table.
Just playing stuff.
Let there's one table that's mostly empty.
There's only like a dealer there and one like dude.
He's like pretty fat and he's just sitting laid back like this.
He's smoking a cigar and he just keeps waiting for anyone to sit on the table.
Is there anybody else gambling at any of these other tables?
Yeah, yeah.
I'd have your table that everyone's gambling.
So I'm just going to walk off.
I'm going to be like at the door.
I'm going to be like.
Everybody got the plan.
All right, peace.
I'm just going to.
I'm going to go start watching other people gamble and be like,
ooh,
I said.
What is everyone else doing?
What was the progression where we need to go to the get through?
Basically, when big and get invited to the private table.
What are with the senior owner games do I see right now?
You see one of the guys that I mentioned was sitting and there's the dice game on that table.
And the other tables are pretty much the same.
One of them is just a plain old roulette.
And that's it.
I'm going to leave.
I'm going to leave by the own words on the map.
Sorry.
I can't see the map.
Oh, you can't see them up on your token.
No, I don't have a token down.
You do the South.
Yeah, there it is.
I have, I don't have a vision on it.
Oh, you don't have vision.
Why is that?
You have dark vision up to 60.
I cannot see the map.
Just reload.
I'm going to leave.
I'm just walking around.
I'm just doing right here.
He's hitting big.
I'm telling you he's hitting big.
Come on, guys.
The guy.
Who the hell are you?
I don't.
Bro, I'm just hearing you on.
I see you.
Come on, big fellow.
He thinks, man, I need.
I need.
He goes, okay.
What do you think I should put it on?
All on red?
No, I'm going to leave that up to you.
I think.
I'm going to leave that up to you.
I'm feeling good.
He goes, okay.
I'm all in on red.
He puts the chip.
All of his chips on red.
And the person out the table spends the rule.
He's going to put the chip on red.
And it lands on black.
Hey, man, I tried.
I tried.
Hey, do it again.
Do it again.
I'll give you a good.
If you don't have anybody.
Come on, bro.
Don't give up.
Hey, homie.
Next to me.
Come on.
Give them something.
I'm broke.
I just want to see people gamble.
This place.
I'm going to throw it in the middle.
looks
good
ooooo that's three六es
ugh the guy on the table goes
uh all right uh but we didn't
better not hear what the fuck
all right? I'll say like the poor
was for now.
uh 2,000
in the bear. 2,000 bellies was the
pool uh you put down 1,000 he put
down 1,000 and you got 2,000
bellies okay? Just keep track of
what how much were you running?
uh both we bet a bit more yeah
you don't mind do you uh mr. what's
a name?
last good I need.
Make sure you are not "sığım, ch adolescent".
Thanks a lot.
Damn, okay, but that's not a good name.
He goes, his name is...
"Mondermis hoax".
You can call me just hoax.
That's got to be five with me.
He goes...
Enough burning around.
I bet 100,000 buddies.
Couldn't you put up that kind of cash?
Boy.
I'll double it.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna raise 100,000 too, down.
So the part is right now 400,000?
Do you have that money, though?
Yep.
He will.
Wait, how much money did you guys hide on here?
Let me check.
Saplier had 300,000 buddies.
In like their bag, I think.
Yeah, 300,000 on Saplier.
So I'm gonna say you took the money that you took from Kiro and handed it to Roma.
Let me just send that back to you, actually.
Roma.
You mean the baptism?
Baptiste, baptism.
Okay, except this, Baptiste.
Alright, so you have 300,000 buddies bag.
You have 2000 extra from what you went right now.
But you already gave like 200,000 to the table, right?
So the part is now 400,000.
The person at the table goes, okay, roll your dice.
The guy is gonna roll his dice.
Oh, I guess better luck me next time.
Roll for your dice.
Yeah, I know.
56 again.
No advantage.
Why did it do?
Oh, I selected your token.
Yeah, wouldn't you have advantage?
It doesn't, it doesn't matter for now.
Okay, you rolled poorly, I guess.
All of them are different.
You can roll your, wait, you're not using the load dice.
That's why I'm not saying this is an advantage.
You're just using the dice, the, the, the, the, uh,
But I thought he ate his berry that gave him advantage to dice.
And then, what I'm gonna say here, use your, uh, tank, the, uh, so you can change the outcomes of the dice.
Oh, so you roll again, your reroll.
So reroll 5v6?
Yes.
Uh, you see as your table gets more and more money, uh, yeah, two, that's a tie.
So what we're gonna do here, uh, uh, more and more people are coming towards your table,
because the game is getting a bit intense, because now the part is like 400,000.
Uh, he's gonna go, who will we put some more money into this?
Uh, I'm gonna raise another 100,000.
Now, I put some more money, uh, on the table.
More people just start to come close.
Even some of the Marines get interested.
They, as they patrol the area, they keep, uh, covering over the table.
Yeah, so sad with that showing interest.
Or as if you were like some random Marine grown.
All right.
Uh, so yeah, he raises by another 100,000.
What are you gonna do?
I'm not.
Matches bet.
All right, you put another 100,000.
Now I don't think you have any money, except for the 2000.
So that, that, this is it for you.
All right, you, we go again.
Oh.
Oh, gosh, no, these dices are shit.
One, two, three, four, five, geez, that's like a straight flush.
Is this short straight or something?
I think that's what it's called.
It's a straight flush, but it ain't, it ain't nothing in this one.
That is true.
We just got to get up here.
You can roll and then, yeah, you can do it all if you don't like it.
Left clear.
All right, you do, uh, as everyone sees, uh, you went, everyone started sharing.
Even the Marines are looking at it and they're like, damn.
That's, that's some big money they got.
Uh, so how was the, how much was the part?
4,600,000 now, right?
600,000.
So you take the 600,000 and you can keep playing.
But this guy is going to leave.
You're like, well, I'm going to do this.
I don't know how I'm, I'm right it out.
Uh, to the point.
I said, I told you I take all your money.
He looks like, oh, what number?
He leaves a bunch of other people come to the table and they're like, uh,
care to go and not around with us.
So they're like, three people came up on the table.
Yeah.
I'll take 500,000 and to bet that you can match this, you can join.
Uh, one of them just looks at the amount of money.
He's like, yeah, man, this is, this is too big for me.
I'm going to leave.
Uh, one of them just walks off.
Uh, as Robo screams, uh,
you want to move around and talk to any of the Marines.
You can do that.
Uh,
all right, the other guy he's like, uh, you know what?
I might give this a try.
He puts down a hundred thousand on the table.
It was 500.
500?
All right, yeah, he's going to put down 500 then.
Uh, goes.
That's win big.
A million bellies, baby.
This guy seems addicted to gambling.
Is the third person not joining?
No, no, he loves.
Uh, ooh, that's two sixes.
All right.
Tomorrow, sir, it's your turn.
Check your message or could I say?
Do you guys cord?
Let me see.
Yeah, yeah.
Gotcha.
It's going to be an automatic success.
Oh, that was.
What is that?
That's the damage.
Yeah.
I didn't think about it.
Oh, five, six.
Yeah, keep ice.
To to to.
Okay, this is a tie, but you can change it to a one if you want.
I will change it.
No, just just click on your ability and that's it.
You have one charge on it.
How many charges do you have on it?
Well, look at this was the tie.
I'll just roll again for the next turn.
See if I can just win with the next one.
Yeah, yeah.
Does he rolling again?
No, no, he's not going to roll again.
He feels pretty happy about his two sixes.
Destroy.
Oh, we got two six.
Oh, this is two sixes again.
The guy at the table goes, okay, you got to raise another one.
Put more money down on the table.
I'm going to put another 50,000 down.
How much?
All right.
So another part is a million.
One hundred.
Yeah, a million hundred.
I'm shit.
Robo's losing his shirt.
Yeah, I didn't see that on money.
All right, let me roll.
Five, six.
Jesus Christ, come on.
Oh, that's two twos and two fours.
Actually, well, all this is happening.
It has definitely has saffelia.
I've been seeing like Marines going in and out of the like private area or not.
I'm just a single Marines standing here.
And he hasn't moved.
He has not moved from his position.
Is that like where is when ring where it is?
Because he has not seen them come out of the bathroom in a while.
No, not the bathroom, but the private area.
The bathroom is right behind the private area.
So yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can see my thing.
This is this is the marine area I'm talking about and red is here.
Yeah, and it doesn't it doesn't seem like people are going in and out of it.
No, no, no, no, no.
There seems to be sort of like a back door to the place.
This is like the front area.
There's probably a back entrance where people can go out of.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Hit this roll big fellow.
Yeah, that's it.
That's a tie again.
He's going to go.
Okay.
I might roll this one again.
Five, six. He's going to reroll.
Jesus Christ, I keep selecting the wrong tokens.
That's two sixes. That's better than before.
I'll reroll again.
If I don't like it, we'll do what I need to do.
Oh, that's a lower roll.
So you might lose this one if you don't turn the two into a one.
So you can click on your ability.
And I'll say you just turn that two into a one.
All right.
So as the dice start to roll, you see the two starts to land.
And as you see that, you just move your hand a bit.
And it creates a space in the area, which pulls in the dice.
And due to gravity, it just flips to the one side instead of
landing on the two.
And that's going to be a win.
So you take one hundred and a thousand, sorry, one million and a hundred thousand
bellies with you.
As you win the guys like,
I'm just bullshit.
I call, I call, he's cheating.
The Marines in the back are going to go, all right, sir, you have to,
you have to leave.
You can't say stuff like that.
This is, this is a fine establishment.
You can't dismerge the people working here.
We have surveillance all over the place.
If there was any fault, play, we would have noticed.
I scored this guy out, this Marine is going to escort this guy out of the place.
He looks at Sapplya as he's passing through and he just gives them a look.
And that's all it doesn't really say much.
Nice doing business with you.
The guy at the table seems to be calling one of the, like, the employee at the table is calling one of the
Marines and he whispers something to him.
This Marine is going to go to the other Marine and talks to him for a bit and he's going to go back to his station.
While this is happening, the other Marine, the bottom is going to go up to his position as well.
This inside this, look there, like talking about.
You were close enough to hear like some whispers, but not and you didn't get exactly much.
You just saw his lips and you determine can you do an insight?
Oh, that's good.
So you determine he says something about bring the box or something like that from reading his lips.
So he go, the Marine goes inside this Marine and he walks outside as he walks outside, you see.
Seeing that and actually going to hearing that, I'm going to stand up and act like I'm leaving for the after chase after.
Now question, would, would Sapplia and Red be listening since they have the radios?
So that if like they have any radio chatter, we're like, hey.
Yeah, but if a Sapplia has the radio on the computer, red, I'm not sure what they're doing at this point.
I'm going to say, guys, I'm going to say my radio towards you and he's going to say, well, well, well, if it isn't the famous masquerade.
Name solution, the owner of this fine establishment.
I'm surprised you showed up at this place. I've heard about you in the underworld circles, but mostly thought you were a myth.
I see you have your acquaintances with you.
Friends, I suppose you look said Roma.
I'm reaching the end of the week.
Yes. I was acting like I was leaving when I heard that they were getting the boss. So he had to chase after me.
If you wouldn't mind, would you like to join a private game as you've got a bit of money to spare? And we're looking forward to that.
Before you have any money, well, we might talk some business. You never know.
I'm going to go back to the end.
So this guy is going to lead you to the back rooms and he's going to signal the marine to step away.
The marine steps back a bit and he's going to follow you and the marine is going to interrupt Roma before heading inside.
He goes only one person.
I don't know if you have the invitation, sir.
What? What? Did you see him when big over there? I just want to see. Can't watch for the window.
All right. Sir, what do we do about this one? It's fine. Just let him inside. Lucie, Lucie goes. He's going to go inside. Let me move inside. Actually, yet they go.
Sape, what are you going to do?
You and Red can communicate right now because there's no one around really to see what's happening.
I was thinking they were going to be on there like the local guys radio channels just to see what they're talking about.
The Marines are what Marines Marines inside Marines outside.
The Marines inside.
You can try to do that. But most of the Marines are just posted and looking at their respective tables and seeing if there's anything, any commotion going around. Not much.
You can try to listen to the radio outside. They're not chatting on the radio inside the place.
That way. Do y'all think you'll need me in there?
Well, you can't talk to them right now. You can only talk to Red.
I'm unable to manage the barriers to add the amount that I have.
I'll never mind.
You probably.
In the bag of berries, you can update whatever amount you have.
I just think I just think so.
Okay.
So what are you guys doing? Supply a red.
Red just waiting to pass them.
Red still making or they're making part.
This is right to head inside and check up on red.
It's going to go.
Excuse me.
I'm going to say there's probably a doll somewhere. Yeah.
Should we say sure?
Now, Safely is what in that Marine go into the bathroom.
The Marine is going to go inside.
It's going to see like an outline of your feet inside.
Like the foot part through the stall.
And you're going to go.
Are you all right in there, sir? You've been in there for quite a while.
Red doesn't even reply, but he's just been like singing to himself very loudly and off key.
Okay.
It's going to go.
Hello.
All right, sir.
I'm going to ask you to step out.
I'm going to make fart noises.
It's going to go.
You've been there for quite a while.
You need to step out.
If you're not going to play, you have to go out.
Yeah, I'm going to go out and see.
So I'm going to go out and see if you're going to play.
Okay, I'm going to go out and see if you're going to play.
So I'm going to say there's a lot of things going on.
So I'm going to go out and see if you can see.
I'm going to get out and see if you can see it.
I'm going to go out and see if you can see it.
What do you mean?
What do you should know who the fuck I am.
We're the same rank.
We're just a little bit yellow.
And then you can roll for attack.
Exit.
Oh.
Oh, put down.
Put down the amount of bellies you have on the thing.
Okay.
Not bellies, just the.
Basically, a million is thousand.
10 million.
Sorry. 10 million is thousand.
10 million is thousand.
You said, let's just watch.
Doesn't it?
I don't know.
I see now how we showed up.
So about these would just have to sit someplace.
Yes.
It's just 10 million is one thousand.
So you just put down 100.
100, 110, sorry.
I will quite to to see.
Proof.
All right.
You guys can see the table, right?
Okay.
What you guys can do is just join.
And you can see it, right?
Yeah.
There you go.
Proof.
All right.
Let's start the game.
This will be fine.
How would sit down and he goes.
So what do you think?
Like put it down, Mr. Masquerade.
There's no.
no practicing going big. It's a big end. All right, let's just start with 100,000 Shaly.
20 basically 30 and it's raising 20. All right, my name? All right,
might I ask what kind of work you do? Okay, ask your friend over there. He seems to know a lot about me.
What did you say? Sorry. I said ask your friend. He seems to know a lot about me.
Lucius is going to go, well, we've heard about Mr. Masquerade quite a bit. He takes some jobs for
the underground. If you ever need that, of course you do, Mr. Albert. You've been
investor for quite a while. You might need someone like Masquerade to run your jobs. Here is
another 20. All right, let's see how well you play. Let's check your cards.
Well, I guess that didn't pan out well for you, Mr. Masquerade.
He signals, he seems pretty happy with himself. He signals the marine to step out of the chamber.
He's going to go give us some room, shall we? Would you? So the marine steps out. He sees
him and he goes morning. He just steps away and just starts to lose you and then he leaves.
Hey, man, come on, you just want that hand. Take a drink, bro.
I'll wait for a bit before we get serious. You just won 100,000. That ain't serious?
All right, Mr. Masquerade, I'm going to ask your friend there to calm down. Let's make this a bit
interesting. Let's go with Mr. Manager another 40 Mr. Manager, you got to you got the guards.
Let's get it. Let's start. Come on. Let's start smoking.
Putting me on already. Wait, do you? Oh, you have all in? Okay. What you can do now,
I'm going to say using your fruit ability, you can maybe change how it appears to other people,
like the cards. Okay. I don't need to. Okay. You won. You won, man. Right.
But in case you need that, I'm going to say you can do that. All right.
Well, that was not a bad hand, Mr. Masquerade.
How about you go all in? All in? Yes.
Oh, I timed out. Okay. Okay. I'm just doing another hand. I don't go all in.
I'm fun with going all in.
He's going to call.
Oh, this is this is looking of it.
Smoking. Holy shit.
Oh, my goodness. This is crazy.
All right. That was above the more. Mr. Masquerade. I'm impressed.
How would you like to work with the Wargome and Bank? We could talk propositions.
Talk about the property of our company. He just lost some money and is offering a job manager.
Come on. Get the cigars going. Come on. Pronto.
Lucian goes, well, Mr. Howard, how about we give this guy a chance and let's listen to
all of you in some of the wine. Lucian Howard goes, sure, why not? I would like to get a bit cosy here.
Rommel, you can pour the wine into each of their cups.
Say less.
All right, Baptist's student.
Ooh, we're playing big, I see. No matter. Let's go all in.
He said all in. He said all in.
He said all in. No, no, he just raised 40, I think.
He's going to be better than another 20, 200,000 basically.
He said all in. Go on. We'll work with this.
Sure, let's just go with that.
You're going to go all in and he'll do this. Damn, okay, you didn't have to do anything.
What? Are you going to pour the wine? Oh, yeah, I'm pouring that. I'm giving some to the manager.
I'm giving some to this guy. Are you sure you're going to give some? I'm pouring.
He looks at Baptist and he's going to go, well,
guess first, I guess.
I could have used that last hand. Let's just see what the cards have in store for us first.
All right, he's not going to drink it then.
Oh, I'm sweating this. It's getting nervous.
It's better than other.
That's a major. Lucian doesn't even have poker plus. What a bomb.
Sorry.
That was making it a good.
Lucian doesn't even have poker now plus. What a bomb.
Who's holding the cards?
Yeah, he's going to fold here.
He's folding.
No, that's all of it, right?
Yeah. Let me do. Just check.
Go all in.
Yeah, I'm going to hold my cards for a bit.
Jose!
You're going to go, oh, how much should you raise?
Yeah, raise.
He said all in. He said all in.
No, holy shit. You're clearing him out. Jesus.
All right, I think it's about time. He's going to just take a sip of the drink.
He's going to go.
He's going to fold this hand. He just takes a sip of the drink.
I'm holding this hand.
Soon after, he will, I think that's it. We can just call it here.
He's going to leave and head to the bathroom outside.
Oh, my God, Lucian.
Just give me a bit. I'll be back.
Not feeling quite well.
He heads inside the bathroom.
He sees one of the doors is broken and the other one is already occupied.
And he sees you. Are you inside, Red?
Isn't he still hiding?
Like, the one of the doors was broken, so I don't know if they could still hide.
I don't know. I guess I would try to hide.
Okay. Do give me a stilthroll.
How small is he?
He's pretty small.
Like, five, five, eight, so could he possibly like be standing on the other body?
He sees you right inside and he goes, oh, what happened here?
The doors broken.
Kind of shrugs, any points to the stall with like the feet underneath.
It's taken a long time.
Oh, I see.
He kind of stumbles and he
like rests against like the sink and whatnot and soon after he falls unconscious.
Red tries to kind of catch him and then just kind of quickly drag him into the stall with the broken
door.
All right. You drag him inside.
What are you going to do?
I'm going to put the door back.
Probably not perfect, but just kind of set it back.
Oh, take the key, of course.
You look through his pockets.
You see a weird, then-and-mushy.
You can't tell what it's for, but it's like one to one connection,
kind of like the normal, then-and-mushy essentially.
And you see a small notebook and of course the keys.
What are you going to do?
Just the keys.
And I'll just look through the notes just see if there's anything interesting.
Just briefly looking through it.
Okay, the contents of the notebook I can tell.
You see the ledger mentions bribery payouts, illegal, well-nobal asset laundering,
loan forgery schemes, private drivel fruit trades, debt owed by powerful pirate and nobles.
This is like the checklist of things that's inside the ledger.
You can look into it a bit more if you want to.
So yeah, upon seeing a guy comes in a bathroom.
Stapleo will give it a moment and then enter the bathroom herself.
Go inside the bathroom with a can.
Yeah.
nod to red as red as right-flin through the guys.
And she'll go up to the broken door and use her tools to fix it.
Okay, do tools do we need to put this?
Do carpenter's tool, sure.
Yeah, you put down some nails on the door and it's it's propped up.
Well.
Okay, what are you guys going to do now?
You can take the ledger if you want to.
You can take the dynamo sheet or you can just take the keys and just go off.
I think red's just interested in the keys.
All right, red takes the keys.
What are you going to do with the body?
Properly in the toilet.
That's why he picks the door or they fix the door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, just make it look like he's also taking a shoot.
If I keep it, I'll be knocked out for a hot minute.
All right, so Lucien goes, he's inside and he talks to the other two and he's like,
that's weird, it's taking a bit too long for Mr. Halward to come back.
I'm gonna I'm gonna step out and take a look.
He steps out.
He looks like I'm in the way.
Okay, you can tell him the way he goes.
Anything that matters, Mr. Masquerade.
You promised me more than just money in these bets.
Okay, what do you need?
What do you have?
Yeah, that way, most of the connections.
Me and Mr. Halward have been investing in this.
Well, you can say an idea, mostly, but we feel like it's going to play well.
In the future, I see you've got some money on your hands.
None of the Marines notice you as you move out red.
You can just head out of the casino if you want to.
Yep, just whistling on the merry way.
Roll a roll a deception, though. Roll one deception for me.
Just to see if you can like easily move through it unless okay.
One of the Marines is going to step forward and he's like,
hello there, sir.
The the the Marine that was with
Halward is this one. He's gonna go
did you see Mr. Halward step inside?
He's gonna go to
red. I just kind of like who?
Oh, it's gonna go well, it's weird because I saw Mr. Halward step inside.
Did you not see him and he went inside?
You know the guy with the suit and all that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, many suits.
Okay, many suits back there.
Many suits. Okay.
Well, is he all right?
You seem to be in quite a rush.
Nope, just finishing my game.
It's sapally an ear sight like in.
Yeah, yeah.
Because then he could interject and be like, he was using the bathroom.
Got to be very soft.
All right, um, okay, the Marines gonna start to go inside the
bathroom now. While Lucien talks to Baptiste about this opportunity that they've been looking
into. What are you gonna say about these?
I'm gonna need more details on this opportunity than this.
How about we just went Mr. Halward this year?
If he's needed to be here, then I guess that's not a worthwhile bit.
So what else do you have?
Well, that's that's all the
one of the things that we had with, but I'm sure Mr. Halward has some more jobs
his way. So if you still don't want to wait, we can reschedule for another time.
You feel free to leave for today. I think Mr. Halward is probably a bit under the weather.
He's taking a bit too long a little worried.
If I leave today, I will not return.
All right, he's gonna go well, I guess this is a this is goodbye then.
The the Marine is going inside the
bathroom and anyone going to check here, you guys are gonna just let him go inside.
Since both doors are closed and it looks like people are just taking a shit.
He's gonna lock at Halward's door still to check if he's all right.
There's gonna be no response.
You guys can head out if you want to.
Roma and yeah, he said one.
Let me move you out.
I'll make sure my people hear about how
West
his experience was.
If he's only passed out like he could still make
Halward could still make grunts and moans. So like it could totally sound like he's
open.
So it'll be like snoring noises.
Like the outside is here down here down here.
What's up here?
That's just attached like sauna or something.
Saplier you're the only one here. The Marine is going to go check on Halward.
He doesn't get a response. He will open the door.
Hold up up. I'm having some difficulty right now.
Saplier get the fuck out of there.
That's a plan.
Alright.
Yeah, Saplier will see that one Marine go into the bathroom and we'll just walk away.
Well, I guess that's a successful rate.
I mean, I didn't think this is going to go like that easy
with the poker and everything if I would.
This is why we plan shit out so it does go easy.
Alright, I think next session would be just going to the bank somehow and not get noticed.
I don't think it's going to take a long time for them to figure out the keys are missing
and everything and you would hear last guys they saw.
I guess we're just straight from here straight to the bank because the bank follows.
Nobody's really going to care that people are like walking down the street at night because it's normal.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
We'll continue and I will.
I'm just barely there.
Thanks.
You still have the tab open.
Let me check.
It was 900.
Yeah.
910 rate so 9 million 10 100,000 9 million 100,000 that's your total take.
And the dude wanted a hundred million for the ship.
This better be a bomb ass ship.
The chips this ship is 20 million.
It was 20.
Yeah, it was 20 million.
Yeah, 9 and 20 million for the whole ship.
You still are not there.
All right, I think the next part would be the bank next week.
Yep, so get ready for that.
I see I see combat coming by real sea.
We'll see if you guys managed to.
So we did a need to stay away from that.
Hey, come on now.
No, we don't want to get that.
We just can see the rail list.
You know, like I was trying to bankrupt him.
Yeah, I mean, he didn't he didn't bet all of it,
but it's mostly there.
He just had like another million left.
He kept saying I'm going to go all in.
That's all.
He's going to go to gamble.
Also, I don't I don't think he cares about 10 million.
That's probably not his.
Where we just that was a good one.
That was a good one.
I'm trying to get them to bet like a special item or something.
I didn't even have to I didn't even have to like do to distraction.
Like off to the side like cough, I didn't have to do none of that.
Like I didn't have to be stable.
That's what I'm saying.
Like we didn't even have to.
Yeah, that's how it's our works.
That's that's a best part.
Like we didn't even have to cheat.
Well, I had to cheat to get in there, but once I got in there,
yeah, that's what I'm saying.
We just walked away with a steady nine mil like.
Thank you.
I mean, with 300,000.
That's what I'll say.
I went in with 300 came out nine mil.
God, hey, that's a golden skillet right there.
You know what I'm saying?
Diamond and crested.
Diamond I am.
Link's over there.
No, I didn't quite a skillet made gold.
That's.
All right.
Uh, well, I guess this is it for now.
I'll see you guys next week.
Yep.
See you.
Bye.
(c plane engine roaring )